a huge victory for free speech and a
huge bummer for censorship happy dweebs
at the White House that's you Jessica
the White House a federal judge has
temporarily blocked by the
administration officials from contacting
social media companies it comes after
the White House pressured big Tech to
block or remove content they disliked
the major platforms have a
responsibility related to the health and
safety of all Americans to stop
amplifying untrustworthy content
disinformation and misinformation
especially related to covid-19
vaccinations and elections they have to
do more to reduce the misinformation
that's out there we're flagging
problematic posts for Facebook that
spread this information it shouldn't
come as any surprise that we're in
regular touch with social media
platforms
what's your message to platforms like
Facebook
and the media is going to bat for the
White House's censorship agenda
as government has to have the right to
have its own free speech to push back
when they see things on social media
they think are dangerous this is one of
the most aggressive far-reaching rulings
you'll ever see what this judge is
purporting to do is to micromanage
really the day-to-day interactions
between essentially the entire executive
branch all these agencies that are
listed as defendants and the leading
social media companies it's not as
though the FBI has been going in and
saying hey take down this post hey take
down this post that's what they're
alleging but there's just not a lot of
evidence to support that judge judge
judge the judge built a case and he
showed that every example of bias went
in One Direction and we talked about
this before whether it's about covet or
the laptop it always seems to go in a
way that benefits the left and harms the
right the judge identified right covid
masking lockdowns lab League Theory
opposition to the validity of the 2020
campaign let me tell you something this
case is huge this is a very significant
case that has the the ability of course
go all the way up to the Supreme Court
the issue is very clear whether or not
the government has the right to
basically suppress suppress free speech
and they did it repeatedly they did it
during all of those things I referenced
from the beginning of time people have
disagreed on what is true and what isn't
true all of a sudden this government
comes in and says we are the Arbiters of
what's true and don't you dare say it if
it's not true and we will suppress you
if it's not true I had my own tweets and
my own Facebook postings uh uh
suppressed and and removed it is a
bottom line where this white house is
against the decision kjp says you know
we don't agree with it but this is the
government who's trying to decide for
the people what we should say what we
should read what we should think and
what we can talk to each other about it
and Kudos goes to people like Dr Robert
Malone Dr bhattacharya the doctors who
put bhattacharia who put their their
reputations and their neck out there
because now we find out that the
government who's so concerned about
disinformation was wrong they were wrong
about everything that were shutting us
down about and so now the damage has
been done and five years later people
are saying you know doctors have been
trashed where do I go to get my
reputation back where do I go to be able
to identify myself as a credible
physician or a credible person and this
was election interference at the highest
level with the suppression of the laptop
which the FBI knew months before and
said that it was Hunter's laptop they
then are coming out Homeland Security
and Department of Homeland Security the
FBI saying we don't know if it's true so
it's Russian disinformation this
Administration is one of the most
corrupt administrations we have seen in
the history of this country and this
decision will bring it to the uh to the
to a okay Jessica while the judge was
talking you were nodding along in total
agreement don't tell the audience I knew
it was a single shot
so but then you this this okay A Higher
Ground I bet we could all agree on is
this is the problem when you talk about
disinformation or misinformation the
person who judge judges it who is the
person who gets to judge that and that
person ends up being the one who
suppresses it so that's why you saw it
all from One Direction because you guys
happen to be in power that would switch
if a republican was isn't that the
danger
it is the danger but there's also a lot
of danger embedded in this judge's
decision because he doesn't acknowledge
the fact that Donald Trump was President
for the beginning of covid when the lab
League Theory came out he was in power
and his administration talked with the
social media companies the same way that
a Democrat would so this judge made it
seem as if there was no government
censorship
until January 21st 2021 as if Trump who
by the way is has the greatest president
ever
I'm coming to that
um I was going to start with that he's
someone who openly went after the social
media companies constantly yes and when
the Matt taibi files came out I know we
talked about this and he included things
that the Biden team had asked about new
to be clear it's the Biden team because
it was a campaign not the administration
talking about please take down the
photos of Hunter Biden's penis you know
it's being blurred out in this or that
and then we get to the testimony where
they came before all those committees on
Capitol Hill we found out that Trump was
actually asking for people to be thrown
off Twitter like Chrissy Teigen for
calling him a dirty name which I can't
say on television but you all know what
I'm what uh what she put out there so it
just doesn't add up if you want to have
an honest conversation about the
orwellian aspects of what a government
can do that's fine but dates matter and
it matters this is the honest
conversation well I I think it's only
maybe going to be me talking about the
dates of this and also the hunter Biden
laptop that was in in October that had
nothing to do with the Biden
Administration taking over unless you
believe that everyone who works in the
government is evil and is a secret
liberal and wants to make sure that's
that secret about it what are you
talking about they're all Republicans
wait a minute what are you saying
October with the laptop
2020 was when the laptop story was
censored Joe Biden was a candidate for
president and not the president it was
censored it was it was the whole thing
and in 1984 it's the government to
benefit Joe Biden when the FBI did it
the FBI was the one who was telling
everyone not to publish it when the FBI
were the very same people who wouldn't
verified it so again it's every
high-ranking law enforcement official in
this country is against Donald Trump and
the Republicans just to get that
straight well you would probably you
would probably agree that Donald Trump
was contentious against most of them so
it's not all that uh crazy to think
perhaps they had a bias back against him
I mean Christopher many people in your
party and I can't say you specifically
because I've been blown up my memory
doesn't stretch that far but many people
in your party were very adamantly loud
about how Donald Trump was against his
own intelligence Community Time After
Time and against his own doj or put Bill
Barr in place just so he could control
uh the doj and tell him what to do so if
Donald Trump needs somebody to tell the
doj what to do that tells me that
they're not exactly his friends in the
in the intro but this is what I'll tell
you I really don't care if it's Donald
Trump or Joe Biden or anybody in between
go after every single person in the
government regardless of administration
that told social media companies they
had to take things down that were true
or put things up that weren't like I
don't know it only going to take 15 days
to slow the spread the facts will spread
will prevent spread Mass Stop
particulate spray wearing rubber gloves
helps it wasn't from a lab we didn't
fund the research Andrew Cuomo is doing
a good job all these things that they
told us were really great and we needed
to believe and if we didn't believe they
were going to ruin our lives and they
proceeded to ruin our lives if it
happened under Trump if it happened
under Biden go after every single one of
them and to the very least maybe the
cowards that want to control Our Lives
by lying to us and manipulating us will
resign and take their pension I don't
care necessarily if it goes to Biden I
don't need to sit here and make him I
don't need to sit here and make Biden
the bad guy because hopefully people are
saying
Anthony blinken it was Jim Comey are you
telling me Jim Comey was on Donald
Trump's side he tried to set him up for
this whole thing
responsible for Hillary Clinton loses
the Americans founded in the the most
untrustworthy candidate they had ever
seen Danny don't you find it strange how
like there's been a flip on the sides of
like you will have conservatives who uh
criticize Tech uh uh for I don't know
not uh let me put it this way
we the the right used to want them to
cooperate and the left used to want them
not to cooperate and now it's flipped
that yes and so now you have
conservatives defending big Tech from
the government right and the government
is uh you know there's a there's a part
in the case where the judge says it
knows that social media companies were
terrified of political retaliation if
they didn't comply with dictates and we
know that from the Twitter files and
also from Mark Zuckerberg's interviews
saying that when the government calls
and says we need like this is a problem
then you listen to them because you are
concerned about that I thought it was
interesting that the New York Times
quoted disinformation experts I don't
know if there's any like less credible
people at the moment on disinformation
Experts and they're so worried but I do
like that this is getting us back to
principles because Trump and Biden will
be no longer in the picture in a few
years so then in terms of on in the
presidency so then you have this issue
of what is the role of government when
it comes to social media companies
because that's not going to stop and the
White House talked about talked openly
about our social Media Partners
and the government is also going to need
to talk to them though if you remember
there's been very there's been a lot of
criminal cases we need in that phone we
need to know exactly who was he calling
when was he calling where were they who
are the other people they're talking to
there are anti-terrorism tactics that
you want to use in order to have
communication so this case is not the
end but I'll be very curious to see how
the Biden Administration appeals this
because they're in a bit of a box they
certainly are a box full of cocaine
yes I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now